Hi, I am Phil Sali,
the pastor of Discipleship at Community here at Henderson Hills.
And tonight we're gonna be talking about the role of the director in community
group ministry. The sound of a single violin.
It can be good now it can be off awful, but it can also be good.
But it takes an entire orchestra to appreciate a symphony. Now,
both a single violin and the symphony are good, but,
but one is good and one is glorious.
And so the reality of a glorious symphony captures the essence of the role
of the director, and that is team building. In every area of life,
the power of teamwork is evident, whether it's in music like a symphony,
or in sports, or in business, accomplishing a big project.
And even within the context of spiritual leadership, uh,
building a strong team is essential for accomplishing the purposes of the
organization. And so, as community group directors,
we're called not only to lead,
but also to equip and build the team that works together harmoniously
to achieve God's mission. So we'll be talking about three important things.
First of all,
the biblical principles that demonstrate the value of building strong teams.
Number two,
building a team to that fulfills the five purposes of a community group.
And then lastly,
we'll talk about seven competencies of an effective community group director.
So first of all,
let's talk about biblical principles that demonstrate the value of building
strong teams. Principle number one is the wisdom of delegation. Now,
in Exodus 18,
we see a beautiful story about Moses and his father-in-law,
and how teamwork can alleviate the burden of an individual leader.
So, uh, Moses is serving the children of Israel after the Exodus,
and people are coming around him to help them with disputes. And, uh,
he's not done this. And so his leader, uh, his father-in-law,
Jethro, says to him, what you're doing is not good.
You're gonna only wear yourself out, and those who wait for you.
And so he shares with him the importance of building teams and the wisdom of
delegating tasks. The number two principle is the strength of working together.
We see in Ecclesiastes four,
nine through 12 about the strength of companionship and the power of
teamwork. It says that there are two better than one, and if one falls,
someone can help 'em up. And if one gets cold, someone can warm him up.
And so building team fosters an environment of support and encouragement
and even accountability. And so as a community group director,
you're gonna prioritize the building and the unity and the comradery
of the leadership team for your community group.
And what will happen is then trust will build,
and then resilience will grow among team members.
And so that when challenges arise, and they all do, uh,
we face them together as a leadership team knowing that we have a strong support
system. Number three, the power of many advisors.
Proverbs 1114 reminds us the importance of seeking wise
Counsel and guidance. It says, where there's no guidance, people fall,
but in the abundance of counselors, there's safety.
So this principle not only applies to the nation of Israel,
but it also applies to teams and organizations that when directors surround
themselves with a team of advisors,
they bring a diverse perspective and godly wisdom from different outlooks.
So a well-rounded and diverse team offers valuable insights,
different approaches to problem solving,
and leading together leads to better decisions and better outcomes.
Then we talk about God's design of spiritual gifts.
This is a beautiful thing that God has done for us.
In Ephesians four says that he gave son to be apostles and prophets and
evangelists and shepherds,
or pastors and teachers to equip the saints for the work of ministry.
Goes on to say that God gives each of his children as spiritual gifts.
And those gifts are meant to equip the saints for the building up of the body of
Christ until we all attain unity in the faith.
So each member has a unique spiritual gift.
It's like a talent that when combined together creates a powerful force for
accomplishing the five purposes of a community group.
And so as the community group director,
your job is to enlist those with different gifts to serve in different
capacities,
ensuring that all the aspects of the five purposes and mission of the community
group are covered,
and that the team operates together harmoniously and unity and fruitfully.
And then down in verse 16,
it emphasizes the significance of every part doing its work together.
It's an analogy that kind of underscores the interdependency of team members,
the body of crisis described as a physical body,
and it has to work in harmony to function properly. Uh,
number next is the, uh, beauty of spiritual fitness. In one Corinthians 12,
a completely different book than Ephesians,
Paul compares the body of Christ to a physical body and identifies this
beautiful thing when the body of Christ works together,
as each member has a specific, specific gift and a unique function,
and no gift being insignificant. Well,
in the context of building teams for the community group,
this principle emphasizes the importance of embracing a variety of leaders
from different backgrounds and cultures and experiences. And God has unique, uh,
uniquely gifted each member to be a creative and influential part of the team.
The director then celebrates these differences and then creates an environment
where every team member's voice is heard and valued.
Then we are speak about the call to serve. And first, Peter, for one,
reminds us that each gift, each has a gift.
Use it to serve one another as a good steward of God's varied grace.
What that means is, is that directors lead by example,
showing humility and a servant's heart.
And when their team members see their leader, the director serving selflessly,
then they're inspired to do the same.
And so serving together serves to strengthen the bond between members and
unites them for a common purpose. Next,
we're gonna talk about leadership development. Leadership, uh, development is,
is a core value for every healthy organization,
and there's an urgency for developing future leaders.
For those of us that are, uh, in our, the second half of our life in 30 years,
uh, will not be leading effectively if we're even alive. And so,
developing leaders that are younger than us,
developing leaders that can carry the torch is, is the best option.
And what's great about community groups is that we already have an amazing tool
for leadership development. Did you know that if Henderson Hills Baptist Church,
uh, would double its leadership, uh, influence,
then we could triple our effectiveness as ministers of the gospel?
And so, uh, this training tool is already in place week after week.
Our church is actually training future leaders, and, uh,
we're working at becoming intentional about building within our community groups
scores and scores of potential leaders who are discovering their
potential to serve God as apprentices.
So directors create a team that then enlists
apprentices. And in what's what's happening then, is the curriculum for, uh,
leadership development has already been written. Uh,
classroom sites have already been built. The mem uh,
mentors for leadership are standing by and the future leaders will
follow if we give them an opportunity. Uh,
community groups are still one of the very best leadership boot camps for our
church.
And so team building is a huge biblical principle that aligns with
God's design for his people.
It enables directors to fulfill the five purposes of the community group more
effectively and empowers team members to use their God-given gifts
to advance God's kingdom.
And so the director enlists the team and delegates the task
and fosters community support,
and then seeks many advisors and embraces spiritual fitness.
And in doing so, they,
they all serve together with humility so that they can unlock the true power
of teamwork. Uh, this next slide is an example of, uh,
the kind of, uh, leadership we're talking about here.
Here you see the five purposes of a community group, reaching people for Christ,
teaching people the Bible, ministering to one another,
serving the Lord as a community group,
and integrating the mission and vision of the church in the community group.
Well, one person cannot accomplish those five purposes.
So we've matched those five purposes with potential leadership opportunities.
Reaching people for Christ is primarily done by the outreach social leader
teaching people. The
Bible of a course is done by the Bible teacher ministering to one another,
then is followed up by another leader called the prayer care leader.
And serving the Lord together, we will talk about it at a different time,
is a done so by the mission's leader. And then lastly,
integrating the mission and vision.
That's your job director as a disciple maker to reduplicate yourself
and the leaders and their apprentices.
So let's lastly talk about the seven competencies of an effective community
group director.
There are seven competencies that every community group director can master,
and then in doing so, become a great leader for the team he or she has built.
Number one,
the community group director must know and understand the five purposes of the
community group. We just went over them, uh, reaching people for Christ,
teaching people the Bible, ministering to one another,
serving toge the Lord together as a community group and integrating the work of
the mission and vision of the church and the community group.
So you have to know those and understand them because, uh,
beyond understanding them,
you must effectively learn how to convey these five purposes to your leadership
team. And, uh, number two of these competencies,
the community group director must organize or reorganize the community group
effectively. Uh, the,
the leadership team will result in promoting a healthy and effective,
uh, path towards spiritual and numerical growth.
And not only does the community director need to understand how to organize the
community group,
he also needs to understand how to build and effectively equip each member. And,
uh, I will be coming alongside all of our directors to help you do that.
Number three, uh,
the community group director leads the work of the community group. Uh,
the key areas of the community group director include vision.
The director of the leadership team needs to learn to, uh,
to pray and pray for a strong, healthy,
clearly understood vision and a growing fruitful community group.
And, uh, number four, the community group director,
enlists and equips leaders for the community group. This is, if,
if you forgot all other seven competencies,
this one right here is the number one,
and that is that you equip and enlist leaders. It,
it's your job to understand the leadership needs and then to take the steps in
discovering and enlisting the needed leaders. Um,
you'll need to discuss it during your community group time. You'll, uh,
you'll need to be on the lookout for those who, uh,
may have had experience leading or those who show the potential for leadership.
Uh, you'll need to determine, uh, uh,
the right path for determining this enlistment process.
How do we do this? Uh, do they shadow me for a little while?
When do I give them an opportunity to express their own leadership abilities?
And so, uh, that's the equipping process and, uh, uh, it's,
it's on you. Uh,
one of my favorite community group directors is a little lady named Linda Casey.
And Linda was the director of a, uh,
Community group, uh, of senior adult ladies. And, uh,
most of these ladies had gotten to a point in their lives where they thought,
well, I'm done here.
But when they came into that Linda Casey's community group as the director,
she says, well, you better get ready to serve here.
Nobody just sits in this class. And I'm not kidding you. Everyone had a role.
And that class grew and multiplied and grew and multiplied twice in
the three years I was serving as her community group pastor. Number five,
the community group director works well with other community,
community group ministry leaders that would be working well with me,
also working well with our elders and our pastoral staff.
The key working relationships are so very important.
Please don't be that rogue Community Group director that says,
I know what the pastor says, but this is what I say. No.
We work together to fulfill the clear vision and articulate the mission,
uh, of our church and the work of the community Group.
Number six of seven is the community di group director supports an effective
administrative process. Now, we will have in our leadership team,
those who are committed to the administrative process, uh,
but it's not just their job alone. Ultimately,
it's the community group director's job to make sure that they have implemented,
uh, an effective administrative process, record keeping,
as well as record reporting and an accurate attendance record,
uh, an up toto date enrollment roster, and a, uh,
a adding process and a dropping process.
This administrative process ultimately falls on you as the leader.
And finally, in our seven competencies,
the community group director understands how to work with and encourage leaders.
Everything we do as leaders rises and falls on leadership.
And so learning how to manage relationships with harmony
and unity, uh,
occurs as leaders establish effective communication and trust building.
Uh, a community group leader that is encouraged,
serves with greater joy and courage and longevity.
And so a community group director should hone his or her skills in
encouraging these leaders and doing so frequently and effectively.
A few ways is write short notes or texts or emails, uh,
make public expressions of appreciation. Uh,
every Sunday you have an opportunity to say,
I'm so proud of so-and-so for the job they've done.
This is how they serve us in their role. Uh,
as you celebrate wins and the accomplishments of leaders on your team,
and you also focus on the needs of leaders, if someone needs to take a break,
you step in for them. You encourage them to find an apprentice when they need a,
a, a break. Uh,
you can also write down requests and respond to them specifically and
quickly. Uh,
don't forget that they need you as their leader and they are observing you. And,
uh, and,
and you can determine the needs of your leaders and you can answer those needs
as God gives you insight and wisdom.
If they're beyond your ability to meet those needs,
then you secure the help of the pastors and, and deacons. And in doing so,
what you're doing is building an effective leadership team. Well,
we conclude by saying this, that, uh,
directors of community groups have the opportunity to influence the future of
our church. They also infu, uh,
have the opportunity to influence the future of the, uh,
future leaders and the kingdom of God. And so, uh,
the future leader is recruited and trained and then develops a
bond with the director. And then that future leader, uh,
learns the passion of the director,
and that passion becomes the future leader's passion.
And the director's attitude becomes the future leader's attitude.
And as the director leads, so then the future leader will lead.
And so a director,
you are primarily responsible for developing leaders for future generations in
our church. And,
and what better plan is there to launch a leadership development strategy than
in our community groups? I'm confident of this, that God is, uh, uh,
is up to something. He is working within the lives of our future leaders.
And you get to be a part of enlisting and equipping and developing and launching
those future leaders for God's glory.